freunde
es gibt im leben zwei wege entweder du
machst etwas gut oder du packst es
vielleicht könnt ihr euch an die letzte
commands folgen wenn nicht blende ich
euch hier nochmal einen kleinen
ausschnitt davon 1
hier wahrscheinlich schon gehört habt
habt ihr nichts gehört außer musik und
dass sie ganz einfach daran dass sich
die tonspur vergessen habe um 20 dezibel
runter zu stellen ich hätte es einfach
nur alles markieren müssen und -20 1
geben müssen
alles wäre super gewesen aber ich hab's
vergessen weil ich das irgendwann mitten
in der nacht geschnitten habe weil mein
netzwerken den event hatte also die
haben party gemacht bei manchmal
netzwerk poker dann war ich mit max viel
unterwegs ab der die blogs bekommen da
muss sie noch zur schule also zur uni
dann bin ich jetzt auch wieder die gäste
am leeren weil ich mal wieder versuchen
schreibe also alles halt in meinem kopf
drin und habe ich das wohl einfach
verkackt beim vorproduzieren das tut mir
sehr sehr leid deswegen habe ich das
versucht jetzt alles zu retten die
dateien wiederhergestellt die im
papierkorb waren und ich habe die
dateien auch wieder bekommen ich werde
das ganze zusammen schneiden und euch
ein vernünftiger qualität liefern und
dabei wünsche ich euch jetzt einfach mal
viel spaß ihr bekommt natürlich am
freitag auch wieder eine folge der
commands also übermorgen und ich hoffe
einfach dass ihr diese entschuldigung
annehmen weil bei der letzten folge
waren halt 2006 1000 sx nur wegen dem
tod ist sehr traurig gemacht dass dann
auch leute in den kommentaren ankamen
und haben dann mich meine familie
beleidigt aber da kann man natürlich
nichts gegen machen euch dann auch alle
blockiert aber ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal die folge und viel spaß weil
jetzt könnt ihr mich wahrscheinlich auch
dann verstehen
vor
löw meine lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft commands heute am freitag
wo ich mir wieder 3,0 ausgesucht habe
die ich ganz nice finde die ich euch
heute mal vorstellen wenn ihr bock auf
diese serie ab würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen wenn ihr das video
angeschaut hat und wenn ihr euch denkt
ich hab doch viel bessere commands auf
lager dann schreibt man einfach in die
kommentare in video roll den command
gesehen habe oder spin link oder irgend
sowas weil dieses commands formular wo
ich das sonst mal mitgemacht hat das
einfach total voll aber ich würde sagen
die formen direktoren mit humor nummer
roman nummer eins ist wieder eine recht
simple sache allerdings eine sache die
jeder irgendwie schon mal gesehen hat
aber ich glaube keiner wirklich weiß wie
das ganze funktioniert ich füge mal dass
hier eben ein dass ein linken wäre ich
jetzt auch fertig drücke und hier mal
drauf geht ihr schon wer das liest ist
doof gibt fragt eric bestimmt der eu
funktioniert es wir sehen hier ganz
viele komische sachen und das habe ich
mich ganz einfach aus einer adventure
web ausgenommen die ich einfach so aus
spaß abends gezeigt hatte und zwar ist
hier einfach ein text den wir hier
einfügen können wir können hier
beispielsweise human zwei einfügen und
damit das ganze nicht in white ist haben
wir hier auch noch kalt da kommen jetzt
einfach auch mal hin schreiben
galler red meine ich geht auch und dann
sehen wir hier schon koman 2
damit können nämlich ganz simpel einfach
so texte einfügen die dann angezeigt
werden eventuell mit irgendeiner klopp
damit dass dauerhaft bestätigt betätigt
wird kann man das auch noch unendlich
lang einfügen und das war quasi auch
schon kommando machen wir mal direkt
dahinter mit command nummer zwei ist
eine sache die ich jetzt hier schon
eingefügt habe und zwar klicke ich
einfach mal auf fertig das ist wieder
ein mega langer command hier das ist
noch nicht mal eine ganze command und
zwar ist es ein nyan cat in minecraft
command sie sah wurde mir zugesendet von
redstone bacon beziehungsweise von
anderen usern meinten zu mir ja hier von
red back nahen video nyan cat in
minecraft mit dem kormoran plan
ich klicke hier einfach mal drauf und
wir sehen schon soll jetzt hier wird
etwas großes erschaffen und gleich sehen
wir auch schon hier ist eine maschine am
start
übrigens an alle die auch diesen fehler
hat mit diesem komischen textur blöcken
und so is connected actors ausmachen das
haben wir viele kommentare
geschrieben blabla hatten wir sehr viele
leute in die kommentare geschrieben
dafür bin ich sehr dankbar und ihr seht
schon wenn ich ihn anschaue läuft alles
extrem flüssig wenn ich ihren schmuck
ist wieder ein wenig weil wir wieder
extrem viel redstone und commands am
werk sind wir können erst hier
draufklicken kriegen wenn ein kalter und
hier drauf dann kriegen wir einen drink
mit remove all entities unterhalt online
kat wir klicken hier einfach mal drauf
und dann sehen wir schon
also dieses alter erschafft quasi
einfach eine katze die heißt neuen cat
und die zieht komisches pulver hinter
sich her also diese komischen
regenbogenfarbigen sachen die man halt
von neid kennt wenn ich allerdings mit
meinem shader dabei hier in die sonne
gucke dann sieht man diese sachen nicht
und auch wenn man weit weg ist sieht man
die sache nicht wenn ich allerdings
daran sieht man wieder die artikel und
damit kann ich quasi einfach so neuen
cat erschaffen machen keine geräusche
die können nichts die fliegen einfach
nur rum und wenn ich das hier trinke
sterben einfach alle
das ist der komplette kader ist wieder
das recht simples allerdings habe ich
mir gedacht ja kom9 cat in minecraft ist
ja vielleicht ganz interessant zum
trollen oder irgendwie so ist halt
einfach nur kann man in vanilla machen
und ich denke mir halt immer so wenn ich
einen server hätte mit einem kumpel oder
sogar jetzt ihre zuschauer wenn ihr ein
server mit dem kumpel oder so und ihr
holt euch einfach in kontakt zu kommen
meine bude oder so da kommt dahin
dann schickt er seine leiden kann das
wäre einfach mega witzig aber na ja das
muss natürlich jeder für sich selbst
entscheiden aber das witzig findet oder
nicht ich find's ganz nice eigentlich
das was möglich ist sondern einen kennt
einfach die rumfliegen rumfliegen die
katze ist klar aber mit den ganzen
partikeln auch noch ist schon mega
witzig das ist einfach commander 2 damit
3,3 ist eine sache die wieder extrem
viel hinzufügt allerdings habe ich mir
gedacht ja kann nimmst es meine commands
folgende dran
ich habe keinen youtube kanal gefunden
wo das ganze vorgestellt wurde sondern
einfach nur diesen command im internet
da stand dann von mister grand hall ist
das und das heiß custom retter
ich füge ich immer den command eine
nation wieder wie lang der command mit
diesen ganzen geschwungenen klammern am
ende um die ganzen sachen fertig zu
machen ich drücke auf den lämmer und wir
sehen schon wieder es wird etwas sehr
sehr großes kreiert also dass es echte
extrem riesiger turm und sobald der rats
am block oben erreicht es verwandelt
sich das ganze hier zu einer reihe von
romanen blogs in der mitte sind dann red
storm blogs und wir sehen schon mister
ghettos super nett aber nie lamotte have
been sold
es kann aus einer zigarette heißt du
nicht kennt auf der website stand grenze
hier steht gar at mag ich einfach den
commander schreiben sonst schaut auf
jeden fall mal bei minister gerne etwas
vorbei der bde thaliana jetzt denkt ihr
euch natürlich hey was hat das denn
gemacht außer ist eine komische
nachricht im chat
immer wenn jetzt die zeit auf fuchs hier
moment ich habe zurzeit übrigens immer
wenn ich aufnehme verändert sich meine
ganzen tasten dann habe ich zum beispiel
wenn ich jetzt denke ich die iks taste
da kommt nix da wenig y taste drücke
kommt ein z also das ist die englische
tastatur die da immer irgendwie kommt
ich habe keine ahnung warum weil wenn
ich aufhöre mit aufnehmen dann ist sie
wieder normal
jedenfalls immer wenn ich times z 0
mache werde schon kommt eingeblendet
korinth temperature 29 das ist nämlich
die custom that a lot im chat steht the
weather is very good to be sure to file
letter code to day also die meinung zu
mir ja ist es sehr kalt du musst dir
eine lederjacke anziehen ich hole mir
jetzt erst mal eine lederjacke und ihr
seht schon ich hab so ein paar so ein
paar effekte und wenn ich jetzt einfach
mal in den game mode 0 gew die schon oft
so kalt so kalt ich muss mich eine
lederjacke anziehen und ihr seht schon
dann geht es nämlich wieder in chat wird
man nochmal gewand des very cold der eu
pass the account or you will be kam zach
also oder man wird krank wenn ich jeden
der raus hier bekomme ich wieder
langsamkeit abbau lähmung und den ritter
effekt und wenn ich sie wieder anziehe
dann seht ihr schon ist mir quasi warm
und das ist quasi die content ritscher
for today
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise einfach
mal wieder times at 0 1 gäbe ist es
wieder besser ist heute der ja okay das
liegt es daran dass ich einfach in der
wüste bin ich müsste eventuell einfach
mal in ein anderes million mal eben
fliegen so ich stehe jetzt hier in so
einem kleinen sumpf bereich da vorne
zwar immer noch die wüste aber ich mache
jetzt erstmal time set 0 und ihr seht
schon das motto der drink alot of water
also da heute ist es zwar nicht kalt so
abholen was er callte und ich halt wie
dumm bin ich eigentlich also heute ist
das wetter relativ heiß und ihr seht
schon meine hunger balken leiste rechts
geht extrem schnell nach hinten also
hier wenig sprit und alles möglich ich
bin in friedlich meine ich sehe schon
gestellt die nach hinten geht und jetzt
gleich werde ich sogar noch mal gewarnt
ja du musst wasser trinken heute
es ist extrem heiß das heißt ich hole
mir noch mal ganz schnell eine bottle of
water die kann man sich hier einfach
holen eine wasserflasche
ich gehe wieder in den game mode 0 und
jetzt gleich jeden moment werde ich
nochmal im chat gewarnt ja als total
heute du musst dir auf jeden fall was zu
trinken holen sind
die trias dehydriert ich weiß gar nicht
genau welches wer sich da genau anwenden
muss da sonst die dies du auf jeden fall
so mehr oder weniger in flammen auf für
freunde meine hunger balken sind jetzt
auch schon am ende also ich kann ja
jetzt nicht mehr sprinten oder irgendwie
sowas im chat wurde jetzt zwar noch
nicht wieder gewarnt doch da ist es juni
to drink water you are getting
dehydriert also ich werde die hydrierung
blabla und jetzt sehen wir auch schon
sofort dass weder herzen abgezogen
werden das muss natürlich immer so ein
bisschen länger dauern weil es kann
natürlich sein dass man irgendwo
unterwegs ist und auf einmal ist die
nacht quasi vorbei und dann ist wieder
tag und dann hat man noch keine
wasserflasche sich zusammen kräften
konnten allerdings stets als auch wieder
einer beschreibung mit need to drink
water you are getting gerettet und jetzt
gleich ich möchte euch unbedingt zeigen
dass mir der herzen abgezogen werden
aber irgendwie kommt gar nicht ich
glaube wir werden gleich er herzen
abgezogen dadurch dass mein hunger
balken leer ist anstatt dass sich die
hydrierung weil normalerweise ist es so
dass ich das gleich steht immer wieder
in der beschreibung keine ahnung warum
aber ich trinke jetzt einfach mal wasser
und dann seht ihr schon yuan out rate
das heißt ich mir geht es wieder gut und
ich kann es erstmal wieder rum laufen da
vorne ist auch gerade so eine komische
drüber mide also das ist auf jeden fall
die custom wetter ich sag mal mod mehr
oder weniger weil es ja quasi einfach
alles noch in vanilla ist das war's dann
auch schon wieder mit dem minecraft für
heute ich finde es mega cool das ist
auch scheiße jetzt kann ich gar nicht
mehr an bord sind die geile sachen drin
das war es für heute mit dem minecraft
command wenn es euch gefallen hat würde
ich mich über eine bewertung freuen es
diese kaste matter what ist wieder sehr
umfangreich gewesen da für die neuen
quad und der command am anfang wo das
funktioniert mit dem text einblenden
dafür recht kurz ich hoffe ich habe dann
eine gute mischung gefunden wenn ihr
kind einfach in die kommentare schreiben
eventuell mal die folge euren freunden